still though tens of thousands of people
are still waiting and they have been for
months to find out if they will ever get
their unemployment benefits Joe Moller
has more on how the state unemployment
office is working to speed up the
process we got a start paying rent here
come Monday and we're still not getting
our funds
Nelson Duncan is a convention a gig
worker he applied for pandemic
unemployment assistance but has not seen
a dime at least 200 calls there it hangs
up on you after 32 minutes of being on
hold Deeter director Heather Corr bulik
says payments are going out in the order
they came in delays for some puah
claimants may be because they previously
filed for these standard benefits the
pool adjudication claims Center is set
to launch Monday individuals awaiting
adjudication of their claim will receive
additional notices and updates through
their employee and B client portal
mailboxes roughly 40,000 traditional
unemployment claims are pending that is
down six thousand from the previous week
corby lake offers some advice for those
waiting go and look at your claim and
the status of your claim and provide any
necessary documentation that's been
requested of you please mail it to us do
not fax do not email way faster for us
to process that more staff is set to
start working the phones Monday
hopefully speeding up the adjudication
process hoping to see an increase in
calls that can be answered we do receive
an enormous amount of calls